pourquoi les inouk n'ont pas rejoint la
convention de la baie james
oui mais venez parole autochtone si
c'est melissa maulin depuis cette
semaine je réponds à la question d'une
chaîne qui va être très difficile de
répondre en une seule chronique
il faut établir que la convention de la
baie james et quand même une convention
qui a été signée en 1975
une autre convention que tu arrivé en 78
a permis aux menaces képi de joindre
justement la convention signée par les
inuits et par les cris à l'époque ce qui
fait que environ 170 kilomètres carrés
de territoire autochtone ont été signés
sous cette forme de nouveaux traités là
pour pouvoir permettre justement une
compensation mais une dynamique
gouvernementale aussi qui est beaucoup
plus large pour les cris les i nous et
pour les naskapis en échange de quoi le
gouvernement québécois à l'époque
pouvaient exploiter les ressources
hydroélectriques et commencer à faire de
l'exploration l'exploitation sur le
territoire qui était conventionnés mais
là on me demande pourquoi les i nous
ayons pas participé croyons pas ils se
sont pas engagés il ya beaucoup de
niveaux rendu là et michel j'espère pour
répondre le plus de façon très concise
et je vais utiliser le document que
j'avais à l'époque quand j'étais au
cégep pour comprendre et je vais te
disant comment que c'était simple quand
même des années 90
ce petit livre de 1991 tu vois la
question indienne au canada montre
qu'elle était la compréhension de
l'inclusion ou l'exclusion des inouk à
cette époque là et le texte dit le fait
que les cris est néanmoins accepté de
signer unilatéralement cet accord est
donc provoqué l'éclatement de
l'association des indiens du québec
la période de flottement qui a suivi a
laissé les autres indiens sans véritable
organisation pour défendre leurs
intérêts c'est pourquoi les communautés
atikamekw montagne elles se sont
regroupées en 1976 pour obtenir une
meilleure reconnaissance de leurs droits
et en février 1975 les montagnes et de
schefferville ont été invités par le
gouvernement fédéral a signé une entente
semblable à celle des cris ils ont alors
exigé que le gouvernement provincial qui
négocient également et des
revendications territoriales des huit
autres bandes montagnaise non résidentes
du territoire de la baie james
s'étant vu refuser cette condition les
montagnes et de schefferville n'ont pas
voulu se dissocier des autres montanier
ont refusé de signer une entente pour le
seul bénéfice de leur communauté
et ça c'est une des meilleures
descriptions que j'ai pu trouver dans un
livre qui ont aussi est très petit mais
c'est vraiment soucier on a voulu faire
signer des groupes en entier du côté des
premières nations et du côté du
gouvernement on a voulu fasciné des
communautés séparément les naskapis qui
ont pu joindre convention de la baie
james
avec une autre convention eux c'est une
seule communauté ckw jusqu'à mach donc
il y avait pas de dissension et a pas de
distance qui avait été créée entre les
communautés
alors que ceux de schefferville voulait
pas justement exclure les autres nations
qui avait elle aussi des droits
ancestraux liés au territoire
conventionnés donc ça lui a pu créer une
séparation dans le modèle de convention
qui a voulu être signé et par solidarité
désigne ont décidé de rester un blog
ensemble pour défendre les droits de la
nation innu alors tu comprends et il
yad'autres niveau que je ne pourrais
même pas exploré en ce moment pour
répondre à cette question là mais
j'espère
que pouvoir trouver d'autres réponses
beaucoup plus profonde beaucoup plus
détaillé mais c'est la meilleure que je
peux te donner présentement sans rentrer
dans des grandes politiques et des
grandes questions de droits ancestraux
versus droit de convention alors merci
michel d'avoir envoyé de la question et
ce n'est pas nous envoyer des questions
n'hésitez pas non plus à partager ses
vidéos
je souhaite une belle semaine